تضرب عاصفه اطلق عليها اسم دانيال ووصفها
الخبراء بانها ظاهره نادره من حيث كميه
المياه المتساقطه خلال 24 ساعه اليونان
لتتحرك من هناك عابره المتوسطه لتصل الى
ليبيا مست العاصفه مدن الساحل الشرقي
الليبي بسرعه رياح وصلت الى 70 كيلومترا
في الساعه وكان ابرزها دارنا والبيضاء
وتكنس والمرج واجزاء من بنغازي وما يحيط
بهذه المدن من قرى ومناطق لكن وضع درن كان
مختلفا ففي المدينه التي يشقها وادي درنا
بطول 50 كيلومترا تجمعت الامطار الطوفانيه
في الوادي وارتفع مستواها شكل ذلك ضغطا
على السدين مائيين يحجزان المياه فانهار
وفق المجلس البلدي بذرنا مما جعل الدمار
اكبر مع امتداد الوادي وحتى وسط المدينه
وصولا الى البحر وهو ما رفع عدد الضحايا
المحتملين خصوصا لساكنه على ضفاف الوادي
من جانب اخر اورد التقارير ان السيول
سببها التفريغ المياه الفائضه عن القدره
الاستيعابيه للسد عبر المجرى المخصص لها
بوسط المدينه وافد لغياب معطيه كافيه
وحديث تقارير عن اعداد كبيره من الضحايا
بين قتلى ومفقودين جراء الفيضانات سرع
المجلس البلدي لمدينه درنه للحديث عن خروج
الاوضاع في المدينه عن السيطره مطالبا
بفتح ممر بحري اثر انهيار الطرق البريه
المؤديه اليها نحن مدينه دارنه مدينه
وتحتاج الى تدخل دولي وتحتاج الى تدخل فتح
الممرات البحريه لان جميع الطرق التواصل
الواصله لمدينه درنه تعتبر طرق الى الان
مقطوعه لا يمكن الدخول لمدينه عن طريق
واحد وهو وهذا الطريق يعتبر لا يمكن
الوصول اليه بتلك السهوله عماره سكنيه
انهارت ومبان جرفتها المياه في دارنا التي
اضحت مدينه منكوبه بشكل كامل كما اظهرته
مقاطع فيديو منتشره عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي يعلن جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ عن
وفاه عدد من الاشخاص في مدينه سوسه شرقي
مدينه درنه وفقدان العشرات لتزداد المخاوف
مع الوقت بارتفاع الحصيله التي تبقى غير
واضحه وغير محدده حتى تتبين خيوط الكارثه
كامله مدن البيضاء واشحات ومنطقه كندوله
جنوبيه الجبل الاخضر كانت بدورها عرضه
للفيضانات والسيول حديث عن عشره القتلى
ممن قضوا بسبب السيول مع توقع مدير مستشفى
البيضاء ان تكون الاعداد بالمئات وفي
الشمال الشرقي لليبيا والتحديدا في المرج
توفي عدد من الاشخاص وفقد اخرون جراء
السيول التي جرفت بيوتهم حصلت المياه درنه
بشكل كبير ولم تتكشف في الصوره الكامله
لتابعه ما حدث ومع ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا
فيها وعدد من مدن ومناطق الشرق ليبيا لم
تتمكن فرق الطوارئ من الوصول الى مئات
العائلات التي حاصرتها السيول